I'm on a mission to make beans exciting
but I'll let this spicy ranch bean salad
do all the talking no really these Great
Northern beans are creamy meaty and
mildly flavored making them perfect for
dressing up however you want I'm making
a simple Ranch vinaigrette using ranch
powder vinegar and olive oil normally
you'd use Ranch powder with some sour
cream or Mayo but today I wanted to keep
it a little bit lighter and then I add
in the crunchy cucumber spicy jalapeno
and creamy avocado and lots of dill and
cilantro for freshness it's come
together in five minutes and it's even
better the next day these little friends
are super sustainable they're affordable
and good for you not to mention the
convenience factor which is why